هذا ليس صاروخا يستخدم في حروب العصر
الحديث انه
ذلك الصاروخ الذي ينقلنا الى ابعد رحلات
استكشافيه في الكون وربما في اهم رحلات
التنقيب عن اسرار الفضاء وحل الغاز هذا
الصاروخ مشاهدينا تلتصق فيه مركبه دراغون
التي نراها هنا سيكون علمتني دراغون اول
امراه سعوديه تحلق نحو الفضاء ريان برناوي
وعلي القرني رائد الفضاء السعودي يقومان
برحله الى الفضاء الخارجي لزياره محطه
الفضاء الدوليه رفقه اثنين اخرين ضمن مهمه
اي اكس 2 وهذه اول رحله صعود الى الفضاء
لفريق رواد سعوديين لتدشن المملكه عصرا
جديدا في استكشاف الفضاء وعلامه فارقه
للحدث التاريخي تعالوا معنا مشاهدينا لنص
عذاب الى الفضاء افتراضيا طبعا
حذاري انها ليست كاي رحله الوصول الى
الفضاء وحده يستغرق نحو 24 ساعه قبل
التحليق لابد لرواد الفضاء من المرور
بمراحل عتاب وتدريبات مكثفه واختبارات
حاسمه وهذا ما مر به علي وريان بالطبع حيث
خضع لكافه البرامج التدريبيه التي
تساعدهما على اتمام هذه المهمه بنجاح
واجراء تجارب العلميه المتعلقه برحلتهما
الى الفضاء تبدا الرحله فعليا مشاهدينا
بالصعود على متن مركبه دراغون اول مركبه
فضائيه خاصه تنقل البشره الى المحطه
الفضائيه تصل حموله المركبه الى اربعه
ركاب من والى المدار نشاهد الركاب هنا في
استديو العربيه لكنها قادره مشاهدينا ايضا
على اعاده كميات كبيره من الحمولات الى
الارض لنستعد اذا لمرحله
[موسيقى]
الاطلاق
بعد انطلاقه من المنصه يصل الصاروخ لسرعه
الصوت ولا ننسى مشاهدينا ان الصاروخ يمر
باعلى منطقه ضغط هوائي ديناميكي وبارتفاع
80 كيلو مترا تتم عمليه الانفصال الاول
بعد سبع دقائق وحين يصل لمدار الارض
المنخفض يتم الانفصال الثاني بعد ذلك
ترتبط مركبه دراغون بمحطه الفضاء الدوليه
هذه هي محطه الفضاء الدوليه في هذه
المرحله مشاهدينا يقوم الطاقه بمركبه
دراغون بعمل مناوره باستخدام الدافعات حتى
يتم الاقتراب والالتحام بالمحطه
ها قد وصلنا مشاهدينا اذا الى المحطه في
هذه الرحله سيجري رواد الفضاء السعوديون
14 تجربه رائده في الجاذبيه الصغرى بما
فيها تجارب توعويه تعليميه يشارك فيها 12
الف طالب وطالبه واثنان واربعون موقعا في
السعوديه عبر الاقمار الصناعيه مهمات
كثيره ولافته بانتظار علي وريان في الفضاء
ونحن هنا على الارض ننتظر عودتهما من
الفضاء السالمين
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات